getting you know human nature is funny
because in the beginning I understand
then cuz my whole thing was like hey
morally I don't want to in fact somebody
else that's an older person I perform
with a lot of people that are decades
older than me I don't want to infect
somebody that is diabetic or somebody
that's vulnerable or has MS or and kill
somebody because I'm gonna I'm an idiot
and I need to be out eating a Pokeball I
felt like that was that's a character
issue you know take a chill pill do some
Netflix calm down but then you know this
goes on and on and on and you're like
what the [ __ ] are we gonna do people are
running out of money they gave you
$1,200 there's no money left there's no
money anyway there's no money on the
outside we're gonna find that out soon
too but let's that's let's wait a few
weeks for that episode everyone's like
open it up it's like okay we'll see but
people are are and and the thing with
human nature human nature is funny you
know whenever you give people the the
smallest idea that they're doing
something altruistic or that they're
doing something for the greater good
they will literally justify any stay
that's when they'll just go and commit a
genocide if they think that they are
doing something that's for the good of
society and you just give them that you
go do this and police each other rat on
each other turn into citizen informants
turn into brown shirts run around like
the Stasi yelling at kids on skateboards
and pointing to people's faces it go
where it's your mask those are the
people that put you in the camp they are
those are the people that throw you in a
camp and and that's what you're seeing
human nature goes there within a few
weeks within a few weeks
people were relishing their new roles as
the enforcers of the quarantine they
were calling the police on their
neighbors they were yelling at children
who were standing
too close to each other there were just
anybody that was having any public
enjoyment out there in the world they
were gonna go and try to rob them of
that and now I had a run-in today at a
run with a cop running with a cop and
I'm starting to notice that the police
now after 9/11 everybody got really
important doormen in buildings in New
York thought they were part of the
Homeland Security Department everybody
thought they were important just like
you know now with the essential worker
and everybody's a hero thank - he writes
eight o'clock the hero thank you who the
heroes again we don't even know the
doctors did it make it 300 grand yet the
nurse is the guide Home Depot - well
who's the hero door - ever the hero
am i a hero can I be here I love my
house today can I be a hero hey I went
to Home Depot I bought something can I
be hero I go to the grocery store who's
a hero we don't know who's a hero
anymore I get it the nurses are working
hard I bought your food enough the point
is this the heroes are getting a little
out of control now they're getting out
of hand
to hear it calling people heroes
apparently does something that's not
really that positive that's why you
never call your kid's heroes because
they turn into monsters if your son or
daughter does something good you don't
sit down and go you're a hero
you don't say that do you know you say
good job Bobby good job you shared with
your sister you don't go you're a hero
because then Bobby would turn around if
I'm a [ __ ] I'm a hero mom I shared with
her and it's like well no Bobby that's
what you should do no I'm a hero
I mean so the tick-tocks
and I get it to blow off steam but it's
highly inappropriate highly
inappropriate wildly inappropriate to
blow up semen many nurses agree with me
many of them there are guests at the
behavior of some of these nurses a guest
and and I'll say it again - delivery
people that are not
getting the food to the homes in time
are not behaving in a heroic manner door
- is not behaving in a heroic matter
they're not so the reality is we got to
be a little careful at that work because
we throw it around we throw it around
after 9/11 every cop and firefighter was
a hero every cop and then they started
choking black people out because they
were having cigarettes industry so let's
be careful with the word hero ah there
are real heroes but it's an individual
thing you know when you brand everyone
in here everyone's a hero that's you
know so I bumped into one of those
heroes today in Manhattan Beach one of
the heroes out there on a go-kart being
[Music]
being heroic on his little go-kart
guarding Manhattan Beach guarding the
wealthy hamlet of Manhattan Beach
California okay whose biggest crime is
when a seagull bothers someone like
Manhattan Beach they would they file a
report for like an aggressive seagull
that's that's the type of community this
is okay a [ __ ] Shack in Manhattan
Beach is six million dollars okay now I
like Manhattan Beach because I like
wealthy Hamlet's that I cannot be
legally kept out of which is Manhattan
Beach I they have to let me come there i
patronize restaurants I know the owners
of the restaurants there's a lot the
best seafood restaurant in LA is
immanent Beach it's called fishing with
dynamite we go there all the time and I
and I they have another restaurant down
there and I hunted I hunt III hunted
them down and I kind of walked into
their other restaurant and I was like
what's hey when's the other one opening
and they were like the one lady was
British so it's coming soon I was like
good and I got food from this
Restaurant / fishing with Dynamite's
great and so I'm in Manhattan Beach and
there is no cars on the road and I'm
with a friend of mine there's no cars on
the road and there's a there's a red
hand signal that you shouldn't cross the
street which applies when there are cars
rules and laws are our conditional you
know they they they are they're there to
govern assay when when you have a
quarantine and no one's really out
driving in that particular area at that
time
it's not essential for me to follow this
rule it's a stupid rule but but I you
know that's why I'm not here oh I'm not
here oh because I I made a real-time
judgment call to walk across the street
and I out here Oh a man who's standing
beside standing between me and the
breakdown of the civil order decided to
come up to me and his go-kart or
whatever he's [ __ ] driving around in
and he's like oh you know what he looked
like the way cops look would like the
flat top hair I mean you know just you
know the guy that just just barely got
the job on the foots why he doesn't have
a car that's why he's in a go-cart he's
extra angry he's gotta [ __ ] be tough
he's that guy you know so he goes water
your door and I'm like I'm crossing the
street I'm crossing the street and he
sucked good points to the [ __ ] he's a
good neanderthal he points to the
[ __ ] red you know dealing with this
monster so he points to the red day and
I go yeah I know but there's no cars and
he goes
wolves are rules that's what he says he
goes rules are rules and then he goes go
back to the other side of the street I'm
like what really and he made me walk
back to the other side of the street I
was on and stand there and then wait and
then he was sizing me had given me that
weird look like am I going to
this guy in jail or not and it's like
this is the type of attitude that these
people have because we would now call
everybody's a hero and we've we've
decided that they are they are standing
between us and the breakdown of civil
society and that they are they are now
and they become brown shirts very
quickly they it's just in their nature
do they love every cop I every guy I
know that became a cop is somebody who
just loves he's either cell they're
insecure people not all of them but a
lot of them are there's great cops out
there are really good detectives but but
there's just an element of the police
force which stems from deep insecurity I
know a lot of guys were like gonna be
like big athletes and then tore the
rotator cuff another drive around Penn
Station and in the little go car thing
and they're cops and like they're not
happy they're not happy that's not the
way they wanted life to work out doesn't
mean they're necessarily bad cops but
they're dicks and when they could be a
dick to you they're a [ __ ] dick okay
and this goes being a dick and you know
what I was trying to [ __ ] do I was
going to the Manhattan Beach Creamery
the ice cream shop to find out what
flavors were vegan and kido
that's what I was doing because I wanted
to bring ice cream to the nurses and the
doctors that's what I was doing I bought
a lot of ice before the nurses and the
doctors and then I realized he was
melting because it was 90 degrees I had
to eat it but I it was for the ER it was
for the heroes it was for the heroes the
popsicles were for the heroes and this
douche bag in his go-cart patrolling
Manhattan B I just I can see something
happening that's not good I can feel it
I can feel it in the scowls of the
people when someone doesn't have a mask
I can feel it you know the old has been
turned against the young now you know I
look 17 I'm thirty-five but I look like
a teenager I present like a healthy
teenager so I am getting scowls from
people because they're like you're
flaunting health privilege is gonna be
next by the way it was white privilege
was male
which health privilege is coming get
ready for that if you're not 600 pounds
with 19 problems you're gonna be an
issue you're gonna be an issue don't you
come here do you have gangrene on your
foot then do shut your mouth I only want
to hear people wear tumors are growing
inside them as we speak